welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and far from home
has confirmed for fans that Nick Fury is
definitely a guy that you need to keep
both eyes on with a huge post-credit
revelation I thought I'd go back through
the MCU and discuss all of the times
that Nick Fury could have beena well you
know what it is from here or now it's
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen spider-man far from home yet and
don't want to know anything about the
film then I highly recommend that he
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into my MCU
breakdown Nick Fury first appeared in
the post-credits scene of Iron Man all
the way back in 2008 and in hindsight it
became clear that due to his dealings
with Captain Marvel in the past that he
was aware that the planet was in need of
some mighty protectors because of what
could be coming down the line fury for
me at this point is 100% human but I
believe that we could see this as the
springboard to start getting contingency
plans in place flash forward to the
Winter Soldier and this is the first
time I think that we see a scroll in the
Marvel Universe fury famously has an
attempt on his life and after he's
attacked by the titular villain
I believe he decides to go into hiding
cut to fury meeting cap in his apartment
and it makes sense that due to the
danger that he was in that he would send
a Skrull bodyguard this would explain
how he's able to get shot by a high
caliber gun and survive long enough to
make it to the hospital Theory literally
tells cap in this scene to trust no one
and we all know how Scrolls love to drop
lines about deception next is Fury's big
death scene that follows hung
concurrently from the prior
assassination attempt Fury's death scene
here always bothered me as I've never
really been able to gel with this
version of events and how he was able to
go into hidin from here instead I think
that this is a scroll on the operating
table and it makes sense as to how he's
able to die and come back later in the
movie I believe that the fury that we
see in the rear end of the movie is the
real one but then the next time we see
the character and age of Ultron that he
is once again being replaced so what
evidence is there to support this well
when Carol Danvers and Nick Fury meet in
a bar
about the midpoint of Captain Marvel
they test each other to see if they can
prove that they are not scrolls as a way
to show that he's definitely human Fury
tells something so secret about himself
that a scroll would never know it and
this is that he can't eat toast that's
been cut diagonally so bizarre a scroll
could never fabricate it toasters cut
diagonally I can't eat it you didn't
need that did you no no I didn't but I
enjoyed it okay your turn
it's a pretty weird remark it seems so
random that it's strange it was even
included but if we look at age of Ultron
there's a very clear reason why this may
have been put in the movie this is
because in the farm scene from that film
when Fury reunites with the team once
more he slices up a sandwich into
triangles before eating it I know that
this isn't toast but you think that the
rules would still apply it's the only
time that we ever really see Fury eat
and those well-versed in film studies
know that food and film is often chosen
for very deliberate reasons from here on
out I think that the fury that we see is
the real one
even in the post-credits scene of
infinity war and a lattice scene and
endgame at tony's funeral however this
made him realize that perhaps he needs
to take a step back for a bit and this
is why he calls Talos to take over and
far from home which is when we get the
big reveal whether we see the character
do another switcheroo remains to be seen
but with Captain Marvel to reportedly
coming out in phase four we might
finally get some confirmation of my
theories with the characters once again
interacting properly with the alien race
a definitely thing that there's been
Scrolls amongst the heroes the entire
time as when they land on earth and
Captain Marvel there's clearly fought in
the group yet only three are accounted
for in the film that means one of them
disappeared and was never seen or heard
from again and therefore remain on earth
probably working with fury and the rest
of shield obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this theory and if you
agree with me or not comment below and
let me know and if you have a theory on
anyone else in the Marvel Universe being
a scroll then make sure you tell me
because I'd love to read it if you enjoy
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my full breakdown of
the ending of spider-man far from home
which would be linked at the end we go
over all of the ins and outs of the
post-credits scene and I discuss where I
think the film's will be going in the
future so it's definitely worth checking
out if
you want to know more I also just want
to let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of Avengers and game to one
lucky winner and all you have to do is
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on my theory in the comments
below the winner will be chosen at
random on August 10th and the blu-ray
will be shipped out from there whoever
gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you